zach is with us in Birmingham hi Zach
how are you good are you better than I
deserve what's up my friend in our hobby
investors and we like to pitch ideas
back and forth to each other about
defense investing strategies recently it
was a hobby investor I'll just have some
some extra money lying around invested
for fun but you're not not to get too
serious with it just we can afford to
lose it but we also like to you know
grow wealth with it at the same time but
it's out it's outside of our retirement
401ks outside of home equity all that
stuff it's just money on the side we
invest all right there's your home page
anyway yes okay good what's your
household income about sixty okay good
and your questions what he told me about
this new thing called peer-to-peer
lending and I was wondering if you've
heard of it and if B what are your
thoughts on it from the investor side
well it's loaning money people who can't
get a loan anywhere else which would be
like pretty stupid what belongs very in
terms of like risk and interest rates
these are all people they're all people
that couldn't go the bank if they could
go to the bank they would go to the bank
and that means they're not credit worthy
and that means these are ultra high risk
loans and no I wouldn't play in that
world not at all not a chance
it's a good way it's a good way to learn
a valuable lesson called losing your
butt and so no I listen I do a lot of
investing a lot and I don't have any
money in that type of stuff
zero and the reason is real simple it's
just it's a fad thing it's like buying
Bitcoin it's a fad thing and everybody's
yakking about it all these people that
don't have any money
are talking about it but as I study
millionaires I don't find any
millionaires I mean like 1% maybe that
are Hobby investors that play in fad
crap and lose their money they're just
they buy really steady predictable
things and they invest in that losing
money's not a hobby of mine it's not one
I like and so I'm not going to be doing
anything in peer-to-peer at all zero zip
nada you do what you want to do exact
but you called and asked me so that's it
hey thanks for the call this is the Dave
Ramsey show